my first thought something juicy
whatever it is that comes to mind rapid
fire and my favorite game called behind
the scenes
bridesmaids oh bridesmaids come on
bridesmaids my first of all
I I signed on to that movie Kristen
asked me to do that movie before they
had written apart for me and I get the
script and it's just a huge sex scene I
was like Kristen hey all right I guess
so I was shooting Mad Men at the time
and I just remember that was it was the
last thing we shot was the first thing
in the movie which was the where we're
rolling around and jumping all over each
other and doing the whole thing and
literally everyone in the crew was like
can you wrap this up because we're it's
Sunday and we have to go home like just
done and we couldn't keep a straight
face because we were having so much fun
Mad Men that was a decade that was
basically my 30s to mid 40s and that was
a decade of my life so there's no way I
could say other than it was the singular
best experience and of all time in in my
acting career and it because it's the
longest it's what kind of gave me a
career it's what set me on my path by
the way did you shoot at actual Essence
no we we I don't think we could they
wouldn't allow you know whatever that's
a working thing we had a beautiful
private home that they have you ridden a
real estelan I have yeah holy yeah it's
pretty crazy it's Bonkers like people
walk around naked like it's always the
people you really don't want to see I
really like walking around [ __ ] like
but one guy decided to keep his cowboy
boots on sure which was really weird you
don't want to step on a bug
weirdest place ever okay
okay Maverick give me a moment what what
morsel juicy tidbit which is now the
highest grossing film I think ever right
of the year for sure my first day on it
I'm in I'm in a
a Navy you know kind of Admirals outfit
that's basically vacuum sealed onto my
body there I'm not kidding there's no
pockets in it because that would make it
look wrinkled and rumpled the shirt has
a thing that attaches under here
to keep it all tucked in tight so you're
wearing a leotard I'm essentially
wearing a Navy leotard
and I'm like I'm walking on a navy base
and there's planes and real soldiers and
everybody and I'm like am I going in the
right place where am I going I don't you
don't want to walk on the wrong thing
and start world war three or something
so you're just like okay and I walk into
this Hangar and I see to the right I see
a four-story
American flag
and to the left I see two F-18 fighter
pilots and right down the middle comes
Tom Cruise like this
full Maverick get up and I'm like oh I
guess I'm in the right place
[Applause]
who is it true that you uh that you
taught Ellie Kemper like to act yeah
when she was in ninth grade she was my
student um how crazy is that so yeah not
only not only that but also in
bridesmen's
um yeah she you know she's obviously
phenomenally talented and I remember my
first memory of that show was you know
30 rocket head wrapped and that it ran
its course and Tina and Robert said oh
we have this part in this new thing
we're writing again and I'm like oh it
sounds great yeah I'll do it like oh
well let it let us let us pitch it to
you first I was like okay well what's it
called well it's about this this woman
who gets uh taken and uh buried in a in
a vault and I'm like wait what uh and we
want you to be the guy who abducts her
and takes but it's funny but it's funny
I'm like
wait a minute hold on a second no no no
no no it's really funny uh and it just
let us pitch it to you so that was how
the beginning of that person
began and look at how funny you are that
expression come on that is a very yeah
I'm a single mom of two girls who I
worship so much and we decided to start
watching Gilmore Girls oh the whole
thing with Gilmore Girls if you watch it
is you have to talk 900 miles an hour
have you noticed this or you watch it
everybody talks about it kind of my
first time being like a guest star on
somebody else's hit show and Lauren
Graham who played Lorelei loreline yeah
Lorelei
was so nice and so kind and now knowing
having been the lead on a show and
knowing how much work she had to put
into it it was like the fact that she
was very nice to the guest star who came
in says a lot so thanks Lauren
you've done all these things you're at
an extraordinary place in your life you
have this great movie coming out like is
there what do you crave next you know
you you talk about it a lot I've I've
listened to you over the years and it's
like yeah you know you affect people
um but like I'm grateful for that I wake
up every day being very grateful for
what I have uh but so I don't really
think about what I don't have uh but I I
just I'm happy being where I am and
hopefully that happiness will continue
so that's pretty much my go-to
day-to-day thought is like let's let's
try to let's try to stay happy that's
gonna really sit with me
thank you
[Applause]
I think it's a good life lesson it
really is it's the best answer ever I'm
so glad I knew there was a reason I
asked you that Jon Hamm be sure to watch
confess Flats in theaters and streaming
on demand now
[Music]
foreign